okay for this video playing mata leão
from canada mata leão i only have two
games in the statistics and this feels
wrong if it feels like I've played them
quite a number of times but oh the
Belgrade gambit yeah that you don't see
too often mostly because it's a quite
quite harmless let's see the main issue
is that black can just develop and
ignore everything does this this is just
a very simple way to play it's not that
black black is better or anything but
just a position where white has
absolutely absolutely nothing there are
also an alliance wear black grab the
grabs the pawn this is some of course
more ambitious and in a way maybe better
but but well just a simple equality
assists not bad okay so we have this end
game now and okay is wants to take care
take on b7 yeah that's true so maybe
taking here is the easiest
rupee to Bishop c4 Ellis's opposite
colored bishops or this one which seems
like very equal getting the King into
the game but maybe a 5 b 5 a-4 is still
something if he if he is a bit too too
relaxed about that should be six don't
want that
I can actually take now play here yeah
well this is not not spectacular but I
can I can still continue to play this
position will be 34 is a bit weak
yeah let's it's a little something very
little but still something that I can
can try to do to make something okay
this is all nicely protected if he goes
through K 1 maybe he can play with us
with rogue a forward I should just try
to to enter here using the active King
ok this is this i need to do anyway
in case of rugae one or something yeah
and now I well Queenie a rook Wow King
III the king III it's a serious move now
yeah he needs he needed to do something
against it and now i'm i'm entering here
and that's a not visit you are probably
very keen to welcome okay here no
you can activate the rookie on the third
rank which is not so nice
not sure how to play this no
a4tech swooped xk org f3 check kingi to
look g3 look at seven King c4 hmm it's
not really it's it's it's just buy one
move it's not working ok this is still
probably right wait roque for is a valid
90 okay on the decades of taking so easy
here droop g3 i will probably play g6
and then go for b5 look III Rocky III
Rocky Sanders king c4 and Isis this is
not convincing or interesting ok
probably I need to take then be 5 e 6
look a 6
hmm very very sharp stuff here rucca on
the 7th I'm expecting but I Camden wow
really is am I not winning this what's
the trick here just winning the pawn or
okay can play e7 and Luka on the 7th ok
this is the drawing idea i see i see i
see now it's probably no way to play
this for win so just take it check maybe
maybe I'm well it's not like I'm clearly
better but I have the more active King
yeah this is this is something maybe I
can somehow play with rookie 5 check
something like that check I don't think
age focus was very very helpful I get to
the pawns now flight from San edge for
most was a lemon I guess yeah I mean
here it looks nice but f4f force I mean
it's the only move but it's a good move
maybe maybe yeah yeah yeah those love
things the solute here i played this and
therefore yeah and here this is the move
pointed out by the comp this is just
stronger it prepares this and white LexA
move if you place he only has moves that
don't help him yeah this one and then a
4chan made this white can still
and this of course but this is still
better than what what I played this is
this is just a bit better for black
simply because there is no no particular
counter plane it's just a bit not just a
bit that blackened blackened tribe but
in the game with F for you had enough
counter play and I wasn't even sure in
some at some stage of if imma be worse
with the porn so I'm very young very
tricky endgame that at the end I managed
also managed to win also because of his
his some time time situation yeah yeah
yeah this is he played this F for years
with analyzing here but black is a bit
better but not spectacularly of course
something something like that I think
white should be able to hold but don't
you don't think it's much but then the
beep on that maybe the computer likes
black here giving him almost upon check
yeah okay i'll rub this up now thanks
for watching